[Musica]
Buonasera Scusate la sedia Ma è piaciuto
il giallo il rosso l'arancione e mi
piacciono i colori pastello
io mi occupo di cose ludiche perché chi
si occupa di cucina si interessa
al divertimento altrui chi fa lo chef di
professione nei ristoranti cura
un'impresa curo un servizio e cerca di
fare una professione che spesso è legata
all'attività commerciale
Io mi sono appassionato di cucina già da
quando ero piccolo e sono quasi 40 anni
che che l'annoso è
me la studio i primi Vent'anni sono
stato un professionista di primo pelo e
sono arrivato all'anca delle ribalte e
poi a un certo punto ho visto che il
lavoro si prendeva la mia vita e ho
cominciato a cercare delle alternative
di sguardo
e ho abbandonato la professione
seriamente con uno stipendio altissimo e
fisso e mi sono buttato per strada
presso ai santi delle strade
perché già nella prima parte la mia
carriera ho sentito tutti i calli delle
mani dei contadini da cui sono
cominciato ad andare perché
non si capisce molto bene oggi chi sia
lo chef a parte un vate televisivo lo
chef
professionista di gravissimo livello
mettiamo stellato eccetera una persona
che ha sempre pochissimo tempo che il
cibo gli arriva in casa e che spesso non
vive più una sua vita ma vive per
lavorare quindi io ho condotto una
battaglia molto forte fra me e me stesso
fra l'incertezza e la certezza e ho
deciso di abbandonarmi al volo il volo
ve lo racconto in piccoli frame sono
circa 3 su Che cos'è è diventata poi per
me la cucina che era un po' la radice
della
appartenenza contadina della mia
famiglia perché è sempre vissuto la
campagna
facciamo propongono una piccola
carrellata perché è un cuoco Chiaramente
deve essere un grande esecutore un
tecnico deve essere un esperto di
anatomia dei pesci e degli animali
terrestri deve conoscere tantissime
Insomma nozioni di qualsiasi tipo e poi
Alcuni di noi hanno delle devianze come
dico io le mie sono tutte di natura
aromatica
perché un cuoco può essere anche un
cosmetico un cosmetico è una parola
bellissima che noi usiamo per
richiamarci ai capelli alle unghie ma
etica collegata al Cosmo e l'uomo che è
allineato su se stesso e che conduce dei
passi di felicità verso la sua vita
difficile
sono uscito letteralmente nei campi
Ah Sono andato già Scusate sono andato
un po' avanti vabbè
è un po' lento
faremo camminare sì
non funziona granché da queste parti
Ecco la potenza della natura abbiamo
visto prima le borragini abbiamo visto
altre piante
negli incontri che si fanno per strada
non sa proprio funzionando sì ecco
Ah ma proprio
è difficile da controllare Ecco la
potenza la natura che riesce a divorare
anche i manufatti che inquinano i nostri
territori
cioè c'è una distanza molto molto forte
tra noi la natura nel senso che ancora
non ci siamo non ci siamo resi conto del
valore della potenza che ha perché per
esempio l'elicriso o le altre piante che
abbiamo visto prima spesso riescono a
crescere anche dove ci sono
ipercolamenti degli immondiziai perché
spesso le piante hanno vissuto epoche in
cui i veleni li hanno superati spesso
troviamo borraggini o Rose fresche
intorno a posti inquinatissimi proprio
perché hanno un'epoca una memoria che
supera spesso gli 80 milioni di anni
tutto quello che vi sto mostrando è
relegato a ciò che diciamo si è sempre
mangiato nel Mediterraneo mi devo
mettere così perché altrimenti
Qui si arriva Insomma al mistero dei
funghi Questo è un fungo classico degli
ebrei un fungo che cresce sui tronchi
che si chiama poliporo giallo
uscendo dalla ristorazione convenzionale
si arriva
alla natura così com'è questa Quercia
viene nutrita in questo momento da
questi due porcini gemelli è un
organismo che nutrirà nei prossimi anni
avvenire quest'albero fino a che
diventerà l'albero che sappiamo la vita
Alba è una pianta che interagisce con le
proprietà soprattutto
Digestive quindi ho cominciato a
studiare il potere che hanno le piante
nella gastronomia perché c'è una
gastronomia ben eseguita ben pettinata e
c'è il lato magico della gastronomia che
soprattutto celato nelle piante che
hanno delle sostanze che interagiscono
col nostro sistema nervoso che non
esiste sostanzialmente sono psicoattive
ma che rendono divertente questa vita e
loro sanno di poterlo fare infatti nel
corso di millenni qualche pianta che
prima non era profumata comincia a
profumare ecco per esempio la rosa di
Damasco è una rosa che si coltivava in
Sicilia fino a 100-200 anni fa essere
all'acqua di rose significava essere
frettolosi il contrario di quello che si
è oggi
e
l'acqua di rose si muove da solo oramai
anarchico quindi scusatemi io mi
e l'acqua di rose si è sempre usata come
disinfettante naturale
Perché abbatte tutte diciamo la presenza
degli insetti essere all'acqua di rose
significava prima essere super veloci
Ora andiamo a una pianta simbolica
siciliana che la pianta dell'agrume noi
vediamo sempre questa pianta ben
impostato con i suoi frutti gialli o
dorati Ma quando si ha la pretesa di
voler conoscere la cucina Gira in fondo
si va alla sorgente questo caso la
pianta si rivela in questa maniera
quindi possiamo raccogliere i germogli
possiamo raccogliere i primi fiori
possiamo usare I fruttini piccoli
Documentati da Federico II utilizzare le
arance amare per il valore che hanno
e soprattutto divertirci con un mondo
Questa è una delle fasi di ricerche che
ho condotto qualche anno fa soprattutto
ci si può
divertire a osservare anche il low cost
design raccolto dai produttori di arance
spiedino contadino usato fino a 30-40
anni fa il bicchiere dell'acqua del vino
per mangiare in campagna in Aranceto e
quindi lo sguardo alla cucina
avviene una maniera più complessa più
larga parliamo di epoche in cui i frutti
si trasportavano con la sabbia
pastorizzata quindi scaldate in forni
che potesse mantenere una conservazione
anche con le uova con tanti altri frutti
si faceva così e anche il legno
dell'arancio del limone ha uno sfondo
gastronomico perché viene usato per
affumicare Le cotture di pizze e pane
quindi è un albero che si commenta da sé
e quando poi ci si porta in cucina
a cucinare questo prodotto si
Acquisiscono tante varianti una pianta
di arancio può avere 12 interferenze
aromatiche una campionatura complessa
per esempio i fiori secchi o il miele
che si estrae dalle Zagare
gli scarti che una volta erano
potenziali l'ultimo anello della cucina
in Sicilia e anche della socialità in
generale era chi raccoglieva le scorze
di arancia Per portarle ai dolcieri oggi
vengono considerate uno scarto Qui c'è
la genesi di una delle prime caramelle
arcaiche siciliane a base di miele e le
scorze d'arance che hanno un effetto
digestivo e diventano la prima caramella
dell'umanità documentata intorno al 1500
proprio da un testo siciliano abbiamo
due piante il timo Il Geranio che stanno
di arancia con gli scarti della Lancia
possiamo fare sia soprattutto con la
spremuta una salamoia che può condire
l'insalata e con le bucce secche
possiamo fare anche di piccoli
condimenti fino arrivare poi alla
potenza del nero lì dei fiori di
zagamara di cui amiamo vestirci per dei
motivi Insomma di vanità
la carrellata successiva
viene da una campionatura di circa 20
tarocchi io attingo
un centro di Acireale che per conto del
Ministero dell'Agricoltura si chiama
crea coltiva circa 1.300 Vanità di
agrumi 20 piante per tipo quindi sono
dei campi stilissimi e sappiate che i
tarocchi d'arancio tarocco per esempio
ne esistono 110 varietà noi chiamiamo
tutti i tarocco in realtà sono 110 qui
Vi faccio vedere 20 forme stasera c'è un
allineamento molto bello perché il
numero dell'arancia è il lotto come gli
intervenuti di stasera Bruno Munari dice
che sono
le arance sono proprio l'espressione
perfetta del Packaging perché sono otto
sacchetti che gestiscono un liquido
importante chiusi in un ovatta Molto
morbida che vi lascio viaggiare e
protetti e impermeabilizzati in tutto e
per tutto per riuscire a viaggiare
Quindi è un frutto che appartenuto
all'antichità al partito dalla Cina
dalla Birmania ed è arrivato da noi in
diverse forme in Sicilia io posso
attingere fino a 1.300 varietà ne ho
provate 100 ma capite bene che tutto
questo quando si comincia a buttarsi con
le braccia aperte verso la ricerca
diventa come dire molto molto
interessante e soprattutto travolgente e
anche stupefacente perché spesso la
ricerca tipo condurre anche a delle
strade più tortuose in cui diciamo hai
anche bisogno di capire cos'è Aristotele
che parla di segale Cornuta nei riti
greci alla scuola di viticurei
uscire dalle cucine per me ha
significato studiare anche la scuola di
filosofia e la storia del mio mestiere
perché spesso È una storia molto molto
complicata da accedere perché
chiaramente la formazione che c'è adesso
in Italia è sempre una formazione molto
molto limitata
però ho deciso di sacrificare molto del
mio tempo perché questo non diventa più
il lavoro ma diventa un'acquisizione
della realtà di quello che c'è intorno
intorno a me al mio lavoro la socialità
è spesso io ragazzi Qua non so che fine
abbia fatto questa questa
scaletta Però mi piace divertente e
diciamo arriverà adesso un po' la foto
per cui poi alla fine io ho fatto una
performance di volontari Perché il mio
intervento di stasera vuole spiegarvi
Che cosa può essere un performer chef
perché
oltre a quelli che sono un po' i sapori
Bisogna sentire anche i sensi Come
vengono coinvolti quindi in un periodo
della mia carriera tre o quattro anni fa
ho affrontato anche il discorso delle
piante psicoattive
e due inquirenti vengono a casa mia a
sequestrarmi due piante di cannabis e
dei barattoli di olive alla cannabis
dello sciroppo di manga alla cannabis
del caffè è una cosa che ancora in corso
però
la performance involontaria accadde
perché 32 paesi del mondo hanno scritto
di questo argomento perché possiamo
immaginarlo Ma io involontariamente
Insomma pensavo Insomma sono stato
liberato subito la mattina dopo
però capite bene insomma che io ho
dovuto sbobinare per un mese e mezzo 15
mila contatti Fra e-mail perché mi hanno
scritto cuochi la de Filippine dal
Messico
ed è successo Insomma così che adesso ne
costruirò un libro anche di questo
proprio perché siamo nelle traiettorie
in cui ci raciniamo dobbiamo
riavvicinarci al mistero delle piante e
capirlo meglio
nel frattempo vai se non la facciamo
vedere più questa che è brutta
nel frattempo
[Applauso]
nel frattempo prima come diceva
il maestro che mi ha preceduto vuol
restare nel ventesimo vuoi passare al
ventunesimo il passaggio è importante Io
per adesso Preferisco rimanere decadente
E nocentista perché mi sembra che alcune
cose dell'Agricoltura italiana e della
produzione dello stile italiano che è
sempre concretizzato in bellezza e
utilità della bellezza
venga insomma in qualche modo recuperati
tutti i dati perché adesso c'è un grande
momento di raccolta dati soprattutto da
parte di ricercatori e di gente che
lavora come abbiamo visto anche nel
campo della ricerca vegetale che è
bellissima e mi sono riversato verso
l'indietro completamente e ho rimesso in
gioco con un amico anche un po' il senso
di quella che è la messa greca Perché in
verità per la parte aninistica della
nostra esistenza almeno nel Mediterraneo
manchiamo di sciamani o di gente che ci
possa guidare a una forma di resistenza
generale e quindi ho inventato sette
anni fa un progetto musicale dobbiamo
esposto tre settimane fa a Melbourne è
un progetto ci ha messo 7 anni a entrare
in un quadro Perché nessuno lo capiva e
questo qui nell'omaggio e vi ringrazio
per l'ascolto
[Applauso]
si possono spegnere queste luci
[Musica]
[Risate]